deux médecins puisqu'à autant d'études
souvent dans un cadre dans le trouble
est drôle chaude pardon la seule chose
dont on est sûr c'est effectivement sur
les enfants de 6 à 11 ans effectivement
il n'y a pas de risque le seul risque
éventuellement mais vous venez de le
contredire c'était que ses enfants
puissent passer trente années il a dit
non au retard des adultes donc si j'ai
apprécié à dinan il a dit non puisqu'il
victime présumée beaucoup d'études qui
ce qui ce qui se contredisent ce qu'il
faudrait faire c'est simplement ne pas
vacciner les enfants de 6 à 11 ans est
en revanche la vaccination obligatoire
pour tous les adultes familles
ration fait restellini sony comme les
écolos
mois déjà je pense qu'il faut arrêter
avec ces messages qui sont volés
vacciner vos enfants vous pas absolument
pas je suis complètement contre faudra
me passer sur le corps pour que maxime
mes enfants alors d'aujourd'hui
[Rires]
bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi faire vas-y tu es plus grave
alors je pense qu'il faut arrêter déjà
avec ces messages qui sont anxiogènes
qui sont délétères pour la santé mentale
de nos enfants des parents c'est tout ça
est très mauvais pour notre santé
mentale on est en train de faire peur à
tout le monde c'est pas possible on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas prôner un vaccin
pour des enfants quand le bénéfice
risque est aussi enfin je veux dire on
n'a jamais un délire chez moi je veux
bien faire un pas comme je voulais dit
voilà vers la médecine je veux bien me
dire que ça évite des formes graves chez
des adultes j'ai des personnes qui ont
des comorbidités etc
j'ai bien envie de penser comme ça je
pense que ça a été quand même démontré
que ça évite forme de revue donc je suis
quand même quelqu'un de très modéré un
don et très tempéré maintenant vacciner
des enfants on nous fait peur en nous
disant qui a une hausse des cas
d'enfants admis en réanimation ils ne
sont pas admis pour deco vide à la base
pour la plupart ils sont admis pour
d'autres maladies on découvre avec des
recherches poussées qu'ils ont aussi été
testés positifs au co vide donc il ya
des cons infection il ya des
bronchiolites comme vous disiez très
justement il ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
sont placés en ligne en réanimation pour
être surveillée parce qu'ils sont petit
leur système immunitaire est encore très
faible et on nous parle de ses enfants
on nous fait peur c'est d'électeurs pour
nos sentiments façon de bouger nos
enfants tranquilles
fiona fiona les contres non alors moi je
suis mais entièrement compte et alors je
pense le pire du pire c'est que ils vont
mettre en place et de vaccination
obligatoire et à obligatoire c'est pas
obligatoire mais je pense quand même que
ça va pardon et je manque que le suaire
de bien c'est que après et vous faire
régner la culpabilité comme ils font
depuis deux ans c'est à dire que l'on
habille les insultes engorger les
hôpitaux mais pardonnez moi y est il ya
treize mille personnes qui ont été mises
à pied parce qu'elles sont pas vaccinés
dans les hôpitaux alors que s'il avait
gardé ses 13000 personnes peut-être
qu'on aurait des hôpitaux un peu plus
rempli et ça se passerait beaucoup mieux
après on va nous dire vous avez pas
voulu faire vacciner vos enfants alors
je ne gagnais pas si longtemps une
scolarité normale evènement porte pas de
rien n'était
citoyen je sais pas si vous rendez
compte de la gravité pour un enfant de
porter le poids d'être regardé comme un
sous citoyen quand on à 9,7 alors
j'étais vraiment c'est vraiment c'est
très subtil parce que tu viens dire pas
obligatoire mais parce vaccinale
maintenir quoi passe vaccinale ça veut
dire le petit leur appui au judo les
appuis au foot il est rappelé qu à la
danse il ira plus nulle part donc il est
sauvé sa société cez l'office arrêté
c'est sa vie elle par axa 6 à 10 ans
assange dix ans a dit elle s'arrête
quand vous parlez déjà 12 ans et de 16
12 ans on n'aurait pas dû le faire à 13
ans on n'aurait pas dû le faire quinze
ans on en est là tu le faire on aura
déjà pas dû vacciner ses enfants là et
là vous vite ils vont pas le faire nous
regarder ce que font l'italie
l'allemagne les etats-unis israël s'ils
le font on tient au fait j'aimerais
avoir l'avis de quelqu'un qui est pour
daniel moreau qu'un enfant de 63 ans
mais aller pour oui alors je précise que
je n'ai pas d'enfant et je respecte tout
à fait des gens comme le lac qui se pose
des questions et je ne sais pas si je le
ferai si j'avais des enfants passe
comment je vais bientôt figure moi
simplement je vous la liste de toutes
les maladies dans l'histoire qui ont été
éradiqués jamais
dans toute autonomie vis à vis des non
mais non non non à la faire glisser on
n'est pas dedans juste temps parce que
la vie des gens dire une phrase c'est là
dit jamais on ait craqué c'est par les
batailles je vous dis qu'on verra des
quelques évidemment
les constructions du coup vite donc on
est la meilleure nouvelle ça serait de
trouver un médicament déjà qu'existe une
nouvelle c'est qu'on est probablement à
la fin de cette phase de crise et qu'on
va avoir de temps des épidémies quasi
grippe
le plus influent les le seul virus qu'on
a aujourd'hui les politiques